yeah that's a sheep those are sheep
[Music]
Nadia the coolest dog ever she's very
independent very curious I work a lot so
it being on a leash all the time isn't
necessarily what this breed is best the
one of Chema's nicknames is important in
Spanish it means a little chunky one one
of the things about the cattle dogs that
we've read is that they're type of dogs
that need to be kept busy so kheema and
it's going to go herd sheep
[Music]
Nadia we are not in LA anymore Kim when
you see the land this is awesome
[Music]
welcome to on the lam hurting oh hey so
what does everybody here know about
hurting here it builds a stronger bond
than any other sport that I know of
their face lights up and the owners face
lights up white oh my god I didn't know
my dog would do that she's never seen
sheep but their DNA tells them to do it
train a dog it's building a team ship
I'm trying to create an independent
thinking problem-solving partners
willing to take my directions he's so
helpful so we bring your dog into the
arena with the Sheep they don't see a
dog they see a wolf and it's gonna be
our job to help that dog to understand
how to make them move and go all the way
around to the other side put some
pressure on them and bring them to me
all right let's go the arena and see
some cheating no no I'm gonna come in
[Music]
so this is like a little kindergartner
in class this is just her brain saying
I'm tired so if I look at them I have to
think about them I'm gonna look away for
a second now I'm gonna come back to work
naughty lady ready watch sheep all right
keep up it's your turn now what are
those things
oh they move oh and I made the move cool
unleash the beast
well let me think about this first and
then I'm gonna cut over here and turn
you this way and I'll cut over here and
turn you that way
perfect good job does she purposely took
him off of me and took him to you uh-huh
I'm gonna work on my dad I think seeing
her having such a great time it's pretty
amazing
her little eyes lit up she would get
them and she was like hey Dad there you
go there for you today was awesome
pure like instinct basically took over
and she barked a lot and once she got
that out she started running in circles
the cattle dog Corgi cross would expect
to herd sheep but I have to say that one
that I had a little bit more fun with
because she was just so happy and
animated was Nadia just her checking
back in with us and why are you sure
this is okay yeah go ahead sit great I'm
going for it
we're gonna have to make more of an
effort to bring her out here it's gonna
be her annual birthday present we should
try to do it more than just like sit
there do more yeah we don't live in a
place where she can do this all the time
and and now that I know she's jazzed by
it
we probably come back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]